weekend is here and pretty soon it will
be packed down at the fremont street
experience yeah the number of people
being safety must be a priority and we
could actually see some changes in that
area starting as soon as tonight madison
kimbrough live near the fremont street
experience on this friday night with
what you can expect if you do head out
there
currently on third and carson with the
hopes of seeing some type of metal
detectors set up but honestly we've kind
of checked around all the areas and we
still haven't seen any and from the
workers i spoke to many expected to see
them up and running by five this
afternoon
a lot of people got guns you don't know
who's got guns you know so it's
worrisome
so they should help chris mcmahon from
sacramento is visiting one of his
favorite spots in las vegas the fremont
street experience and although he comes
down here frequently he knows he needs
to be careful they can do better for
sure more security there's a lot of
homeless people but
i feel
semi-safe and the city of las vegas
wanting visitors to have a better and
safer time in the wake of the recent
violence that has plagued downtown just
last month two men were shot while
inside of the experience one of those
men died and a 16-year-old boy was
arrested the city now implementing metal
detectors at the entrances of the
experience and adding a potential curfew
for those under 21 years old in a
statement the fremont street experience
president and ceo andrew simon says
quote we established additional security
protocols for the special events this
weekend and believe the new curfew
proposal will be integral to our efforts
moving forward when it comes to like
fighting and shooting my kids don't know
nothing about that so if they're out
here and it happens they wouldn't know
what to do it's still unclear how
security would regulate the under 21
curfew but there's already a curfew in
place for those under 18 starting at 9
and 10 p.m depending on the days however
minors are allowed to stay out if they
are accompanied by an adult